empezó a la una y diez de la mañana hora
local cuando helicópteros y aviones y
tropas estadounidenses llegaron a la
zona norte de la provincia de ivy league
y empezaron a atacar una casa una casa
donde pues estaba este líder el de isis
abu ibrahim al-asiri que había
reemplazado al entonces líder de isis
abu bakr al bagdadí la zona era bastante
relevante para isis hasta de hecho este
grupo terrorista tratando de volver a
tomar poder sobre esa zona hacia un mes
había atacado precisamente una prisión
con cerca de 3.000 prisioneros y
entonces rescatistas como usted lo
mencionaba están reportando que hasta el
momento son 13 personas muertas seis
niños y cuatro mujeres en estas personas
muertas y también pues hay que mencionar
que pues varios ciudadanos de la zona
dicen que no solamente esa casa fue
atacada sino también otros lugares
reportando también más heridos ahora
cristóbal le pregunto qué el pentágono y
la casa blanca al respecto y sobre las
muertes civiles
el pentágono ha dicho no ha querido
mencionarse todavía y expresar lo que
pasó frente a las muertes civiles sin
embargo dijo que este ataque fue un
éxito y que no se reportan muertes de
soldados estadounidenses
el presidente joe biden en un comunicado
dijo que éste era un ataque para cuidar
a eeuu y para cuidar al mundo y resaltó
que la valentía y la el talento de estas
fuerzas especiales pues logró que se
sacara del terreno de combate al líder
del estado islámico el presidente job
alguien que estará hoy en nueva york se
pues hará mención de este ataque en la
noche de ayer y en esta madrugada y
precisamente sobre la acción de sus
fuerzas militares para sacar de combate
al líder del estado islámico